[Music]
another emotional performance really
touching this time you move Malby
how did that feel I mean when I saw her
like you know it's so like choking on
her words I mean I felt like I had like
finally I was able to get that
connection across when I saw her like
that way I mean I knowing that I was
like my singing got her to feel that way
I mean it was just it just felt so good
what do you hope people take away from
your relationship in your story with
your mother I want people to understand
that I mean for those of us who are
lucky enough to have our moms with us
treasure them these are women who would
go through Hellfire for you I lived that
everyday with my mom and you know I've
been growing and getting more
independent but you know she's still you
know she's still you know that worried
mom because she saw me you know almost
died I want her to know that you've done
a great job took care of me you gave me
my confidence my self-esteem is intact I
mean it's all because of like the love
we had for them so I wanted to tell her
you know don't worry about me you know
you've done I mean let me worry about
you for one tell surreal is it for you
guys both to be sharing this experience
together ma'am so when this whole thing
first started she was so skeptical but
she was like America's Got Talent
that's it's he doesn't American TV show
like
we do it like no one gets like who gets
into those like not people we know not
us and so it's just been a journey with
for both of us because the more things
unfold it's like mom are you saying it's
not she's like I don't even know what to
say it's like this like fighting
unfolding for both of us
[Music]
[Music]